تخفيض ايام العمل من خمسه الى اربعه في
الاسبوع من اكثر الامنيات رواجا عند
العاملين دراسه جديده موسعه كشفت ما يمكن
ان تحققه تلك الامنيه من نتائج ايجابيه في
حاله تنفيذها الدراسه قامت بها شركه
الابحاث البريطانيه اوتونومي وشملت احدى
الستين شركه وحوالي 2900 عامل في بريطانيا
العمل لمده اربعه ايام فقط يعزز رفاهيه
الموظفين ويزيد من الانتاجيه وفق الدراسه
كما يساهم في انخفاض مستويات القلق والتعب
والتحسن الصحه العقليه والجسديه العمل
لمده اربعه ايام ادى لموازنه العمل مع
الالتزامات الاجتماعيه بنسبه
54%
56 شركه من اصل 61 بنسبه
92% قالت انها مست في نظام اربعه ايام في
الاسبوع
90% من الموظفين ابدوا رغبتهم في استمرار
العمل باربعه ايام اسبوعيا
خمسه وخمسون في المئه من الموظفين افادوا
بزياده قدرتهم على العمل
[موسيقى]